das licht am ende des tunnels so wird
die impfung gegen koubek 19 gerne
genannt war der tunnel der pandemie
fühlt sich gerade ziemlich lang an
es ist eine bedrückende zeit die zahlen
der neuinfektionen auch wieder toten
steigen in deutschland wieder neidisch
schauen wir auf israel so schon sehr
viel geimpft wird und etwas ängstlich
blicken wir auf großbritannien wo sich
die ansteckende virus mutation
ausbreitet und werden wir bald wie in
frankreich eine abendliche
ausgangssperre bekommen lockdown und
impfen wie kämpfen andere länder gegen
das virus unser thema heute in der
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin und wir schauen
mal in ein paar andere länder und dazu
begrüße ich ganz herzlich hier im studio
lehmkuhl journalist in radio europa hier
in berlin herzlich willkommen und auch
hier im studio mit dem blick auf
deutschland jan der wolf korrespondentin
in der parlamentsredaktion der
rheinischen post herzlich willkommen und
zugeschaltet aus london ist uns andreas
stamm erst zdf korrespondent für
großbritannien stimme guten draht nach
london und tel aviv ist uns zugeschaltet
mike lingenfelser erst ard korrespondent
für israel und herr lingenfelter ich
begrüße sie herzlich direkt mit der
frage an sie wir schauen ja nach israel
und denken meine güte in diesem kleinen
land die sind so super organisiert und
die impfen unglaublich viele menschen
viel mehr als hier in deutschland und
fragen uns warum funktioniert das in
israel so gut können sie uns damit eine
antwort weiterhelfen
guten abend israel hat ein interessantes
gesundheitssystem das übrigens auf dem
deutschen basiert jedenfalls hat es das
seine wurzeln durch jüdische einwanderer
aus deutschland also gesetzliche
krankenkassen die aber hier in israel
nicht nur für behandlungen zahlen
sondern auch für die versorgung der
patienten zuständig sind mit eigenen
ärzten angestellten ärzten und
medizinischen einrichtungen und dadurch
ist der kontakt der direkte kontakt zum
patienten also jetzt zum potenziellen
impfling einfach einfach direkter und
auch eine eigenheit dieses dieses
gesundheitssystems ist dass es
digitalisiert ist jedenfalls wesentlich
digitalisierter als unser deutsches
gesundheitssystem daten patientendaten
sind zentral gespeichert viele wichtige
daten sind zentral zugänglich für die
entsprechenden medizinischen versorger
aber jetzt in der gegenwart auch für das
gesundheitsministerium und so lassen
sich im kleene unheimlich schnell
umsetzen und der kontakt zu den menschen
ist sofort gegeben also eine vertreterin
des gesundheitswesens hat gesagt
innerhalb von zehn minuten war im grunde
geklärt wer jetzt eine einladung bekommt
zur impfung und dann einen impftermin
automatisiert über automatisierte
telefonanrufe oder sms über das handy zu
vereinbaren also das geht alles sehr
schnell ist ein struktureller grund es
gibt noch ein paar andere die ihn auch
gerne erzählen aber sie müssen
entscheiden bleiben wir erst mal dabei
also die frage er hat man denn da dann
auch also spielt das thema datenschutz
man gar keine rolle weil wenn ich das
jetzt so höre dann denke ich direkt das
kann man in deutschland gar nicht
irgendwie umsetzen weil hier haben wir
schon probleme mit unserer corona waren
app weil wir da angst haben dass wir da
dem datenschutz nicht genüge tun sich
privat ganz genauso nicht alles was
israel jetzt so reaktionsschnell macht
ist vielleicht in jeder lebenslage einen
vorteil für ein gesundheitswesen oder
eine gesellschaft im moment ist es
natürlich extrem blitzschnell wenn wenn
wenn alle zugriff auf die daten haben
aber alle heißt natürlich auch nicht
jedermann sondern es gibt hier schon
datenschutz aber es wird im vergleich zu
deutschland wesentlich sportlicher
ausgelegt und das sieht man jetzt auch
bei diesen besonderen abkommen dass
israel mit dem pharmariesen pfizer
getroffen hat also die frage stand ja
immer im raum wie kann es sein dass das
kleine israel so viele impfdosen bekommt
während europa oder deutschland immer
noch zu wenig aktie hat und ein eine
antwort darauf ist man hat einen deal
mit leiser gemacht man stellt den dem
pharmaunternehmen wichtigen staaten
jetzt aus dieser aus dieser info
offensive zur verfügung und im gegenzug
liefert pfizer so viel impfstoff das
schon möglichst bald eine
herdenimmunität erreicht werden kann für
pfizer ist das natürlich unheimlich
attraktiv dass hier ein kleines
überschaubares land mit ebendieser
digitalisierung und eine einer datenlage
die sehr überschaubar ist eben für einen
modellversuch im grunde jetzt steht und
das hat der premierminister netanyahu
wie er sagt höchst selbst eingefädelt
mit dem chef von pfizer ok sehr
interessant da reden wir gleich noch mal
drüber über die politischen folgen und
auswirkungen aber schauen wir erstmal
kurz nach großbritannien herrscht am
israel geht da sehr stark voran aber
auch in großbritannien wird sehr viel
geimpft heißt dass man ist ja in
großbritannien sehr positiv der impfung
gegen über die leute sind sehr bereit
auch sich impfen zu lassen
also ich sag mal diese diese sehr lauten
und vehement rufen den impfgegnern wie
man die aus deutschland kennt die gibt
es hier so nicht die gibt es natürlich
aber eben nicht in dieser zahl die not
ist sehr groß also großbritannien ist
eben gebeutelt von corona wie ja kein
anderes land in europa das muss man so
sagen wir marschieren hier auf fast
100.000 tote zu täglich steigt diese
zahl um mehr als 1000 im moment und da
ist kein ende abzusehen
auch die wirtschaft leidet enorm also
der leidensdruck ist enorm groß und das
glaube ich befördert bei vielen auch den
willen und man geht auch so ein bisschen
unorthodoxe wege wie auch in israel denn
erstens hat eben die britische
arzneimittelbehörde entschieden die die
ersten drei verfügbaren impfstoffe
einfach per notfall zulassung
durchzuwinken
man hat also da einfach auf langfrist
daten verzichtet hat gesagt erreichen
uns kürzere daten zeiträume denn wir
müssen wir müssen wir müssen und
zweitens ein sehr umstrittener schritt
den mann gegangen ist
gegen die empfehlung der hersteller aber
auch gegen die empfehlung der
weltgesundheitsorganisation man streckt
die impfung oder man verändert den grund
grund im plan eigentlich heißt es ja
zwei dosen die zweite nach ungefähr drei
wochen und das verlängert man hier auf
drei monate
das ist ungeprüft das ist auch
wissenschaftlich nicht ganz unumstritten
aber es schafft eben eine abhilfe gegen
den akuten impfstoffmangel und man
erst mal so viele menschen impfen so
schnell wie es geht die haben dann einen
gewissen schutz
darüber wird gestritten wie hoch der ist
es gibt da daten aber es ist eben nicht
komplett aber das sind eben zwei punkte
die die britische regierung hier extrem
vorantreibt das hat ihnen einen
zeitvorteil verschafft und eben jetzt
auch einen geschwindigkeitsvorteil und
deshalb sind das aktuell rund 3
millionen die schon geimpft sind und
damit ist man zumindest was europa
angeht alleiniger spitzenreiter
das ist eine ganze menge und viel mehr
als in deutschland da sind wir im moment
bei ungefähr 840.000 die geimpft sind
pro wort wenn sie das hören in israel
ist datenschutz nicht das große problem
also man man hat eine digitalisierte
gesundheitsakte die man ja hier noch
schon lange einführen möchte aber die
wir alle so noch nicht haben wenn und
großbritannien geht da jetzt eben auch
voran weil die not auch sehr groß ist
warum geht das in deutschland nicht so
schnell wie in den beiden ländern
ja das hat viele gründe unter anderem
strukturelle gründe die mit dem
gesundheitswesen zusammenhängen ich
glaube in deutschland ist der große
punkt dass deutschland sich gemeinsam
mit der eu um zu einer gemeinsamen
impfstoffs beschaffung am verständigt
hat verträge auf eu ebene gemeinsam
abgeschlossen wurden
die vielfach kritisiert wurden aber ich
würde das erst mal so sagen strukturell
schon stützen und sagen das ist die
richtige entscheidung wir hatten im
laufe der pandemie sehr häufig die
diskussion ob es zu sehr nationale
alleingänge gar bei der grenzschließung
war das einmal ein großes thema und ich
finde erst mal gut zu sagen wir sind
eingebettet in einen europäischen
verbunden wir wollen die eu stärken und
wollen auch dann die die impfstrategie
gemeinsam abwickeln das finde ich
richtig wie es wird hat ist es natürlich
so auch hier ist die not groß wir sind
mitten im lockdown die befürchtungen
sind ja eher dass die lage sich weiter
verschärft und da will ich dann trotzdem
behaupten dass ein starkes lang wie
deutschland innerhalb der eu aber auch
die die eu als verbunden da noch mehr
mit nachdruck hinter sein muss und ich
würde sagen man muss viel mehr geld in
die hand nehmen um impfkampagnen
aufzublasen also negativ getrieben da
wird sich also einfach um dann mehr mehr
fortschritte zu machen aber das problem
ist dass die leute sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen das problem ist ja dass zu
wenig impfstoff für alle da er
oder es nicht gut genug organisiert ist
genau aber auch in den also in die
produktion würde ich sagen wenn man da
tatsächlich finanziell nachsteuern muss
es möglich sein in hoch entwickelten
industrieländern produktions kapazitäten
hochzufahren
also es gibt natürlich man wird
gearbeitet aber man hätte das vielleicht
vorher machen können
wie schaut man aus frankreich auf das
thema insel und auch auf deutschland die
dann wiederum neidisch auf israel
schauen schaut man in frankreich am
anfang der pandemie hat man ja immer
etwas neidisch auf deutschland geguckt
weil wir bessere zahlen hatten jetzt
sind die zahlen bei uns ja auch sehr
dramatisch wie schaut man im moment von
frankreich aus auf deutschland gerade
beim thema impfen also ich muss sagen
jetzt über diese debatte impfen also ich
musste richtig lachen am anfang die
erste woche in von januar hier in
deutschland große skandal desaströses
impfkampagne der bild zeitung gesagt wir
hatten damals in frankreich also am
ersten januar hatte deutschland 200.000
leute geimpft wir hatten in frankreich
219 also dass und jetzt mittlerweile
haben wir langsam die die die 300 marke
in sicht wahrscheinlich morgen also wir
impfen ungefähr 50.000 leute pro tag
also die impfkampagne hat sehr sehr sehr
langsam angefangen warum weil wir haben
in frankreich eine sehr gut organisierte
und starke zuwachs bewegung also länger
bewegung frankreich hatte im dezember
das niedrigste einen teil der
bevölkerung die sich bereit erklärt sich
impfen zu lassen also nur 44 prozent der
franzosen haben dezember gesagt ich lass
mich impfen mittlerweile ist es 56
prozent
immerhin plus 12 11 12 aber das ist
extrem langsam geworden deshalb die
regierung ist auch sehr sehr sehr
vorsichtig voran gekommen und sagte okay
wir müssen sehr vorsichtig sein alles
erklären nicht dass wir die alten leute
im pflegeheim im altersheim einfach
impfen ohne dass sie eingewilligt haben
und es gibt jetzt also jede franzosen
muss jetzt unterschreiben dass er auch
freiwillig diese impfung bekommen hat
und das ist ein großes also das ist 45
seiten wie jeder patient so jeder alte
mensch in dieser halte haben jetzt
bekommen hat muss das durchlesen und
unterschreiben und dann kommt ein
gespräch mit einem hart also das hat es
ist extrem langsam das war auch die ist
bei den beim medizinischen personal gibt
es da auch mehr zurückhaltung ja genau
an so viele haben auch ganz am anfang an
gesagt ich lass mich mit diesen neuen
form von impfstoff nicht impfen
wir wissen nicht was das ist frankreich
sehr hinter dieser sanofi labor und
sanofi gewettet auf ein klassischer
impfstoff also nicht diese eierei und
deshalb war das am anfang im dezember
also muss ich sagen kommunikativ eine
katastrophe und jetzt nach zwei wochen
ungefähr mitte januar alles gekippt mag
man gesagt ich mach das also viele stars
und schauspieler und sänger hansi sack
ich lasse mich impfen damit die
bevölkerung auch mit macht und es gibt
auch ein bisschen diese mein nachbar
kriegt der hilfsstoffe sticht auch das
armenhaus typisch französisch und nächst
höhere also jetzt ist die kampagne sehr
deutlich schneller gegangen nächste
woche fangen wir an mit impfstrategie
für die leute die nicht im pflegeheim
oder also sagen wohnen sondern auch zu
hause ab 75 jahren aus essen das machen
ja es gab hier den vorstoß von markus
söder im bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
frau wolff der gesagt hat wir brauchen
eine nebenpflicht für medizinisches
personal gab es eine menge kritik daran
sie haben früher für die
mittelbayerische zeitung gearbeitet hier
schauen als eben auch regelmäßig glaube
ich immer noch gut da kann sich damit
gut aus in bayern
wie ist das zu beurteilen warum dieser
vorstoß warum dieser vorstoß das glaube
ich hat politische gründe
aber dann auch ganz konkret einfach mit
der lage ich glaube es ist einfach der
politische versuche mit einer
unglaublich angespannten virus situation
umzugehen deswegen kann ich sozusagen
den impuls schon verstehen dass man sich
überlegt was kann man noch machen aber
die kritik die da an söder laut wurde
die kann ich auch gut verstehen und die
würde ich auch teilen
also die bundesregierung bisher
bundesregierung und länder einfach den
kurs gefahren sind ist so wird keine
impfpflicht in deutschland geben wenn es
sieht wenn man jetzt nun einzelne
berufsgruppen oder gesellschaftliche
gruppen in blick nimmt und dann sagt
vielleicht für die dann doch dann wird
damit ein versprechen gebrochen und ich
glaube dass der politische schaden sehr
sehr viel größer ist als den positiven
effekt den man damit erzielt nämlich
dass seine leute sich impfen müssen also
ich glaube das ist eine frage der
akzeptanz es würden misstrauen schüren
weil die leute dann denken wieso wird
erst die impfpflicht mit sicherheit
sozusagen ausgeschlossen und jetzt
kommen sie doch und dann glaube ich es
auch in der jetzigen situation einfach
viel zu früh über eine impfpflicht
nachzudenken weil wir einfach gar nicht
genug impfstoff haben dass man also
logistisch auch alle impfen kennen das
heißt es ist tatsächlich also das
bestärkt sozusagen eindruck dass er viel
politisches manöver da ist und söder
sein image als der erste corona macher
sozusagen und der schnellste und
tatkräftigsten krisenmanager dass er
dieses image bestärken will ja da will
ich dann eher politisches kalkül hinter
vermutet er da können wir da passt
eigentlich ganz gut der blick noch mal
nach tel aviv lingenfelder wenn man über
politische politische motive sieht und
ich bin hier der korona macher das
möchte präsident nicht ein jahr
wahrscheinlich auch sein oder ja
verbindet den den impferfolg natürlich
sehr stark mit seiner person und das hat
gründe
natürlich geht es ihm auch um die
volksgesundheit aber hier stehen mal
wieder wahlen an die vierten in zwei
jahren und nicht ein jahr ist mal wieder
im wahlkampfmodus und darin ist er auch
quasi weltmeister im politischen
überlebenskampf also er will wenn ende
märz wahlen sind bis dahin möchte er zur
normalität zurückkehren normalität heißt
den lockdown beenden die wirtschaft
wieder öffnen die grenzen wieder öffnen
letztendlich auch die härten immunität
bis dahin mehr oder weniger haben wenn
alle über 16-jährigen geimpft sein
sollen das verspricht er
dann hat man natürlich die genesenen
fälle auch noch die sind ja immunen
quasi hat
willich immunisiert worden wenn wir das
alles zusammenrechnen dann kommt man in
diesen bereich der herdenimmunität wenn
alles gut läuft aber wenn das tempo so
weitergeht wie bisher dann ist das
tatsächlich möglich und die audi ag ist
tatsächlich im märz soweit sein und die
akzeptanz in der bevölkerung für das
impfen für den impfstoff ist auch sehr
hoch nämlich an
ja also israel ist wirklich also wenn
ich das höre aus frankreich oder
teilweise auch aus deutschland israel
ist kein land der bedenkenträger also
also wirklich nicht das ist quasi das
gegenstück dazu und das kann man sich
hier auch ein bisschen abschauen also
die zweitbeste lösung ist oft gut genug
hierzulande man macht erstmal und besser
dann notfalls nach man ist also einfach
viel beweglicher die bevölkerung aber
auch der ganze apparat ist sehr schnell
mobilisierbar das wiederum hängt
natürlich mit dem krisengebiet israel
zusammen mit der kriegserfahrung dass
man in krisensituationen schon oft sich
bewähren musste und hier viel eingeübt
wurde natürlich
und bei aller impfskepsis dies natürlich
hier auch gibt es gibt auch hier
impfgegner in geringen zahlen aber es
gibt sie sind die leute doch relativ
schnell auf den kurs gekommen also wir
nähern uns der zwei-millionen-marke
170000 pro tag sollen jetzt geimpft
werden
also die herren impfskepsis ist hier
verschwindend gering würde ich sagen ich
habe mir noch mal nach london herrscht
am ich habe am anfang sagt man ist ja so
ein bisschen man hat das gefühl dieser
dieser tunnel von dieser pandemie ist
einfach lange das ist es ist winter mal
hat ein bedrückendes gefühl dazu eben
die notlage dieses schlechten zahlen
wie ist es in großbritannien schildern
sie uns vielleicht einfach ein bisschen
die situation und auch wie man mit
ausgangssperre mit all diesen dingen
darauf reagiert ja wir sind momentan
hier wieder in einem strikten lockdown
das ist der dritte und der erste der
wirklich wieder sowie so die die strecke
hat wie man es aus dem frühjahr kannte
also im endeffekt zu hause bleiben das
ist die ansage rausgehen einmal am tag
zum sport arbeiten nur wenn es nicht
anders organisierbar ist was natürlich
für viele immer noch geld
ansonsten sind nur essentielle geschäfte
auf lebensmittel
und und und arztbesuche und und
apotheken
das heißt es ist wieder extrem strikt
und das hat natürlich auch einen grund
denn diese virus mutation b 11 7
zumindest europaweit furore gemacht hat
aber die stammt eben aus südengland und
die hat großbritannien auf dem völlig
falschen fuß erwischt denn man muss nur
mal kurz rekapitulieren am zweiten
dezember kann man hier aus einem teil
lockdown mit schon relativ hohen zahlen
das war schon ein bisschen so dachte man
group das eine gute idee ist die
virologen haben gewarnt aber man hat
sich in den vorweihnachtstrubel gestürzt
auch aus wirtschaftlicher sicht und
viele haben gesagt okay das geht schief
das wird zu einem nächsten lockdown
führen und dann hat man sehr lange
gekämpft um kurz vor weihnachten
wirklich die notbremse zu ziehen und
dann nach weihnachten noch einen lock
down dann richtig strikten drauf zu
setzen weil dann diese mutation dazu kam
und da gab es sehr viele vermutungen am
anfang und da wurde sehr viel
hinterfragt aber ich glaube mittlerweile
kann man schon als relativ gesichert
sehen dass diese virus mutation 50 oder
bis zu 50% ansteckender ist und das hat
dann eben mit den hohen zahlen mit
schlechter regel befolgung die auch dazu
kommen dass die leute sind einfach viel
laxe umgang mit den regeln hat eben dazu
geführt dass hier die zahlen explodiert
sind
das muss man mal so sagen dasselbe gilt
für irland die nachbarinsel die ist
sozusagen importiert hat und daran sieht
man schon sehr deutlich und dieses
grundproblem daran daran laboriert man
jetzt die krankenhäuser sind übervoll
die intensivstationen sagen wir stehen
kurz vorm kollaps das gilt vor allen
dingen für london und den südosten
englands und da ist keine besserung in
sicht denn wir wissen ja neu infektionen
führen 7-10 tage später zu einweisungen
ins krankenhaus von denen die schwere
verläufe haben und dann wieder tage tage
später und eben zu hohen todeszahlen ja
und ich trotzdem sie sagen ja es läuft
steckt man gerade gefangen und trotzdem
sagen sie es gibt auch ein laxen umgang
oder war das nur auf vorher hat sich das
bezogen hat sich das jetzt geändert seit
dieses diese mutation wütet sei also
sind die leute jetzt dann erhalten sie
sich besser an die regeln
also diese woche war hier die große
enforcement weg so würde ich das nennen
also man hat versucht sozusagen klar zu
machen dass die polizei jetzt ganz genau
hinschauen wird dass der normalerweise
recht freundliche umgang der britischen
polizei mit den mitbürgern dass der
jetzt endet dass verstöße sofort
geahndet werden denn man hat auch diese
virus mutation hat nicht unbedingt
geändert dass viele leute eben sich hier
so ihr bett gemacht haben und sich so
ihre regeln auslegen wie es für sie
passt und das war mit ein grund dass die
virus mutation sich auch so ausbreiten
kann weil die fällt eben auch nicht von
bäumen die muss eben übertragen werden
und dafür müssen menschen zusammenkommen
und im moment dafür die regeln brechen
und ich glaube das hat sich noch nicht
wirklich gebessert aber die polizei und
auch die regierung macht klar und
versucht den großen kampagnen jetzt auch
darauf hin zu drängen die zeit dieses
laxen umgangs ist vorbei denn es führt
eben nicht nur zu corona toten sondern
mittlerweile sagen viele ärzte auch wenn
man jetzt einen schlaganfall hat ein
herzinfarkt und auf die intensivstation
kommt dann ist nicht mehr unbedingt
garantiert dass man behandelt wird man
steht also vor einem massiven kollaps
des gesundheitssystems und den will man
eben unter allen umständen verhindern ja
ok vielen dank herr stamm frau kohl wenn
sie das veränderten dieses virus
mutierte virus ist ja auch in frankreich
nachgewiesen worden in deutschland
natürlich auch wie ist die haltung in
frankreich zum lockt dauern weil anders
als hier sind bei unglaublichen
geschäfte noch geöffnet genau also
frankreich hatte im november vier wochen
lang eine strikten lockdown die schulen
sieht aber offen geblieben das ist sehr
sehr sehr wichtig für die akzeptanz der
bevölkerung und also die lehrer lehrer
verband sind extrem wichtig in
frankreich und momentan ist also dass
deshalb sind jetzt die schulen noch
offen
auch die läden und ich war zwischen
weihnachten und silvester kurz in
frankreich ich kann sagen die franzosen
gehen zum friseur zu machen großeinkauf
neue klamotten für die kinderschuhen und
so die läden sind voll also die
situation momentan in frankreich es ist
fast wie september/oktober hier in
deutschland also man darf sich treffen
mit freunden mit verwandten also es gibt
auch keine haushalts beschränkung und
nähe konnte er nicht mehr als hatte
einigen für silvester und wir
weihnachten aber jetzt mittlerweile die
idee ist bitte bleiben sie zu hause
abstand händewaschen
jene maßnahmen aber die leute dürfen ins
büro gehen den metro- und gehen arbeiten
nur es gibt jetzt diese ausgangssperre
ab 18 uhr wahrscheinlich ab morgen in
ganz frankreich bisher zwar als nur
ungefähr die hälfte der seeba team damit
die leute nicht abends noch extra sich
treffen damit sie die leute nicht nach
dem arbeitsstunden sich massenhaft in
den läden noch treffen und so weiter und
so fort das ist jetzt natürlich das
problem also frankreich deshalb war das
auch so vielleicht auch diese resistenz
zu den impfstoff frankreich ist jetzt
relativ lebt relativ gute noch und
deshalb na ja das funktioniert ist ja
eine ganz andere schilder schilderung
als das was wir aus großbritannien dann
hört genau aber trotzdem ist also ihre
zahlen sind die gehen ja auch nicht
runter genau und und man weiß wann hat
das gestern wurde offiziell gesagt ein
prozent der positiven fällen beweisen es
handelt sich um diese mutation also die
britische mutationen also wenn man sagt
gestern hatten wir 19.000 positiven
fälle ein prozent davon es ist diese
britische mutation deshalb es ist jetzt
natürlich wir bewegen uns auf sehr
dünnes heißt also die regierung weiß
einloggt on würde sehr kompliziert seien
für die bevölkerung langsam für den
bedeutenden schule schließen jetzt
wissen wir dass und das ist sehr sehr
kompliziert aber andererseits wissen wir
dass diese mutationen jetzt schon in
frankreich ist und da zum beispiel die
kinder auch betroffen sein können
das gibt das beispiel von großbritannien
das ist hochpolitisch und klebt wolf
wenn sie das hören zum einen in
frankreich wo die geschäfte geöffnet
sind die schulen geöffnet sind in
großbritannien ist es viel strenger und
da bricht das kranke system zusammen
krankenhaus system da ist der
deutschland einen mittelweg wie
empfinden sie das die akzeptanz des lok
downs und was erwarten sie jetzt in den
nächsten wochen von der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wenn die
wieder zusammensitzen mit der kanzlerin
also ich würde sagen dass die akzeptanz
schon relativ großes nach wie vor weil
die lage so angespannt ist dass es
einfach gar keine alternative gibt und
ich meine wir hatten heute wieder einmal
einen tag mit rekord neuen rekordwerten
totenzahlen auch die täglichen
neuinfektionen liegen bei über 25.000
also ich glaube
sozusagen das bewusstsein für die für
die heikle lage für die angespannte lage
dass es schon verbreitet und wir sind ja
in einem harten locker und also so eine
situation wie in frankreich dass man in
leeden geht zum friseur geht es ja gar
nicht möglich weil die einzigen einfach
oder die leiden hat geschlossen haben
also dazu können wir in deutschland gar
nicht kommen
aber was man so hört wird es ja also es
wird nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ja sowieso
für den 25 januar angesetzt
aber was man so hört soll dieser termin
vorgezogen werden in der kommenden woche
also es gibt forderungen danach und das
sieht auch danach aus dass es in der
nächsten woche schon wieder ein
zusammentreffen der bundeskanzlerin mit
den 16 landeschefs geben soll
und dann wird es natürlich um
verschärfungen gehen und ich denke also
dann muss man die frage stellen welche
bereiche kann man noch verschärfen
das werden ausgangssperren sein das ist
glaube ich einen punkt dann sind so
fragen wie zwei masken pflicht wo auch
eben söder in bayern vor vorgeprescht
ist fühlt man sowas bundesweit anders
ich glaube es dann irgendwie so
beispiele für mögliche verschärfung und
jetzt hat noch noch möglich sind
was hier los was ist also wie wirklich
und die maßnahmen sind also wie zum
beispiel diese 15 kilometer regelung da
sind ja viele die sagen das hat man
bringt eigentlich gar nichts da würde
ich in diesem fall tatsächlich mitgehen
das ja auch eine frage der kontrolle der
umsetzbarkeit wie kam das überhaupt
durchgesetzt werden und wenn
also wird es auch sehr stark abhängig
davon welcher region welchem gebiet man
lebt ist es natürlich irgendwie einem in
den ballungsgebieten globalen umfeld das
ganze das andere ist wenn man irgendwie
in potenziellen ländlichen gegenden lebt
wo ein freund 15 kilometern auch kein
menschen begegnet also gut möglich
deswegen würde ich sagen das ist
vielleicht keine maßnahme die die so
ausschlaggebend ist aber nachdem die
zahlen einfach hoch sind zu hoch sind
und man auch eben nicht mehr
rückverfolgen kann das ist eines der
großen probleme
dass man einfach auch nicht mehr weiß wo
finden die infektion denn jetzt noch
stadt dann musst du musst es weitere
massnahmen geben ja und das muss auch
kontrolliert werden dass es eine frage
ist wer auch die frage nach tel aviv wie
wird denn wir haben es jetzt gehört aus
london dass da sehr stark eben
kontrolliert werden soll dass die
polizei dann schaut ob die regeln
eingehalten werden wie ist es denn in
tel aviv im lok dauern wird da genau
hingeschaut dass die leute sich daran
halten
ja grundsätzlich schon aber auch das
gehört so ein bisschen zum lifestyle in
israel dass man regeln nicht blind folgt
sondern sie vielleicht auch manchmal
interpretiert oder kreativ damit umgeht
also die ja dass das befolgen der der
chor ohne auflagen das wird hier immer
wieder kritisiert und auch die die
durchsetzung also letztendlich die die
verfolgung durch die durch die polizei
auch die strafverfolgung
da gibt es immer wieder forderungen dass
das viel strenger sein muss denn das ist
ein grund warum auch hier die zahlen
äußerst hoch wieder sind die zahlen der
neuinfektionen auch wir befinden uns in
ihren israel im dritten lockdown mit
strengen auflagen ausgangssperre von
einem kilometer radius vom eigenen
zuhause
die geschäfte sind alle zu kindergarten
schulen alles zu auch weite teile der
wirtschaft so praktisch im shutdown und
der öffentliche nahverkehr und die
forderung sozusagen maßnahmen auflagen
härter durchzusetzen damit man gar nicht
erst so weit kommt die wird immer wieder
erhoben aber ich beobachte nicht dass
sie das sie dass sie streng durchgesetzt
wird obwohl natürlich von locker und zum
lockdown
immer immer genauer hingeguckt wird aber
ist es denn auch deshalb vielleicht oder
akzeptiert man das deshalb vielleicht
etwas besser wenn man sich hier in
deutschland die diskussion anschaut 1
kilometer das kommt ja das kann ich mir
gar nicht vorstellen dass man das hier
durchsetzen könnte dass man es deshalb
vielleicht auch akzeptiert in israel
weiß mit der impfung da so gut läuft ja
also bin mir nicht sicher im grunde
haben wir im moment hier ein wettrennen
ja wir haben auf der einen also in
wettringen die zeit auf der einen seite
rekordverdächtiges impft tempo auf der
anderen seite eben wieder ein rasanter
anstieg der neuinfektionen auf nahezu
10.000 pro tag bei einer bevölkerung von
nur 9,3 millionen menschen also dass das
ist schon da sind schon kritische werte
die auch das gesundheitssystem wieder
dann an die an die grenze des machbaren
irgendwann bringen werden
die akzeptanz auch der look down
maßnahmen ist ist hier nicht groß
die leute sind müde und es geht nicht
nur sozusagen um so eine so eine innere
ein inneres ablehnen oder müde werden
diese dieser harten auflagen inklusive
quarantäne auflagen und was es nicht
alles gibt und ausgangs beschränkungen
es geht um die ganz harte währung
nämlich die wirtschaft und bereits seit
dem ersten lockdown wurde israel extrem
hart getroffen da scheint israel eben
nicht so unverwundbar zu sein an diesem
punkt die wirtschaft hatte in
nullkommanichts arbeitslosenzahlen von
20 prozent wenn man sieht hier
reihenweise gastronomie und kleine
unternehmen pleite gehen also also
verschlossene türen nicht nur wegen des
lockouts sondern für immer oder
vorläufig für immer also akzeptanz
gering große große corona fateh große
müdigkeit mit diesen maßnahmen an dem
punkt ist das volk hier ausgelaugt und
alle hoffen auf die info glaubt das gilt
für alle die hier die hre die länder die
sie hier vertreten dass alle da müde und
ausgelaugt sind frau kohl aber die frage
sondern wie es der wirtschaft geht wie
wer oder welche rolle spielt das dass
man dann sagt weil eben die ja die
geschäfte zum beispiel noch offen sind
ja ich muss mich auch erst korrigieren
das ist nicht genau wie die situation im
september oktober in deutschland sondern
mehr november weil restaurant der
astronomie museum kinos und so weiter zu
sie hinterher in frankreich also dass
nun aber das stimmt jetzt ist die frage
wenn wir jetzt handeln müssen wenn weil
diese neue mutation in frankreich ist
was machen wir jetzt zu machen wir die
leben zu das bedeutet wir müssen enorm
unterstützen finanz mit so förderungen
geben also damit diese kleinunternehmen
einfach überleben oder machen wir die
schulen zu was natürlich kein geld
kostet oder weniger natürlich ein teil
der eltern werde vielleicht auch
krankentagen anmelden damit sie auch für
die kinder zu hause sein können aber das
ist das ist jetzt natürlich deshalb sage
ich das ist hochpolitisch und die
situation in frankreich ist kompliziert
also die wirtschaftliche situation
das hatte sich ein bisschen sehr besser
die in den letzten jahren
letztes jahr war sehr sehr kompliziert
also wir haben nicht so viel kapazitäten
wie die deutschen das ist klar das ist
deshalb war das auch sehr sehr wichtig
dass wir zusammen wie der eu dass wir
zusammen als europäischen länder
gearbeitet haben für für damit wir die
wirtschaft unterstützen können aber auch
in den rennen für die impfstoffe weil
das war dass das ist immer so ein
einsatz das kursiert in paris und in
frankreich aber auch ich weiß auch in
brüssel sie so hätten wir das alle
separat gemacht na klar hätte
deutschland sofort für die ganze
bevölkerung alles gekauft und wir hätten
vielleicht ab zweite frankreich ein
bisschen aber was wäre dann die
situation gewesen für ganz europa und
frankreich hängt enorm wirtschaftlichen
also mit situation zu den nachbarländern
sowie alle länder in europa und auch
deutschland profitiere davon also wenn
ich das klettern abschieben darf halt
einfach die eu wenn sie gemeinsam
verhandelt einfach auch günstigere
preise bekommen also die die die preise
pro dose sind günstiger wenn die eu als
gesamte mit den herstellern verhandelt
als wenn auch deutschland allein also
insofern ist es auch darüber hinaus was
sie sagen auch für auch für deutschland
einfach ein wirtschaftlicher vorteil
großbritannien hat sich da von ihm
losgesagt hat selber schneller
zugelassen und hat dann halt eben schon
vorher geimpft ist das was herr stammen
was da sehr positiv auf bei dem wo man
gesagt hat hier boris johnson der macht
jetzt richtig weil wir machen uns
unabhängig von der eu zulassung ja dass
die regierung johnson und dann kommt
weite teile seiner anhängerschaft jetzt
nicht unbedingt auf europäische
solidarität setzen man das haben wir in
phoenix glaube ich auch ausgesprochen
den geheimsten vier jahren der praxis
realität geworden aber man war zu dem
zeitpunkt noch teil des rechtlichen
raums der eu und hat eben da eine
sonderregelung gezogen das war ja dann
auch sehr kontrovers in deutschland ob
man hätte das auch tun sollen
aber hier war ganz klar auf europäische
solidarität da pfeifen wir jetzt und
natürlich auch getrieben von von der
lage denn boris johnson das muss man
ganz klar sagen dem wird vorgeworfen und
ich glaube zu recht dass er vieles
vieles falsch gemacht hat in dieser
pandemie manche seine übelsten kritiker
sagen hat fast alles oder alles falsch
gemacht und jetzt hat er eben diese
regierung die chance das irgendwie
wieder gut zu machen
das noch herumzudrehen soweit das
möglich ist wenn man sich die zahl der
toten zum beispiel an schaut also das
ist ja keine wiedergutmachung aber und
hat jetzt die chance mit diesem im
programm sozusagen einen ausweg und das
ist die einzige hoffnung aus diesem
lockdown teil ob dein raus rein das auch
für die wirtschaft eine katastrophe war
denn auch da hat man unglaublich viele
fehler gemacht war immer dieses hin und
her zwischen dem dürfen der wirtschaft
nicht schaden wir müssen da irgendwie
weniger beschränkungen aber am ende hat
sich immer gezeigt dass wenn man
knallhart schnell und dann auch relativ
schnell wieder raus kommt aus der
situation dass man dann wirtschaftlich
besser dasteht und so ist es hier
wirklich alles den bach runtergegangen
und boris johnson der setzt jetzt auf
das größte im programm der britischen
geschichte wirft da alles rein das
militär unterstützt in der logistik
heute
seit heute wird in apotheken geimpft
also es wird versucht da so weit oder so
nah wie möglich an israel ranzukommen
das ist bei einem flächenland mit 66
millionen einwohner hohen schottischen
norden muss dann wirklich auch sehr
einsam wird natürlich wesentlich
schwierig auch was die logistik angeht
aber man wirft hier alles in die
waagschale impfen und hofft somit auch
die kurve in dieser pandemie zu bekommen
damals angesprochen also lieber dann
einen kurzen harten lockdown damit das
nicht ewig weiter plätschert vorwurf das
ist ja jetzt ja auch so ein bisschen die
die diskussion immer wieder dass viele
leute auch sagen wir müssten eigentlich
viel schärfere maßnahmen haben
bodo ramelow der ministerpräsident hat
sich korrigiert hat gesagt die kanzlerin
hatte recht wir hätten im oktober schon
alles runter fahren sollen ist das noch
was wo sie sagen dass der zug ist
sozusagen abgefahren für deutschland man
hätte dass man hat das eben nicht
gemacht und jetzt stehen wir da vor dass
wir immer weiter irgendwie verlängern
und sich keiner traute wirklich den
harten schnitt zu machen
es fällt mir schwer das irgendwie so zu
fassen
der zug ist abgefahren ich glaube man
muss mit der situation jetzt umgehen
nicht stimmt tatsächlich dass bisher
alle vermutungen einer verschärfung sich
eigentlich bewahrheitet haben und wenn
dann im nachhinein irgendwie gemerkt hat
das wäre sinnvoll gewesen wir hätten
früher hart reagiere das finde ich habe
mich elend spannendes beispiel die er
bevor die zahlen jetzt nach oben
geschossen sind als vorbild galten die
haben im oktober ende oktober sehr früh
reagiert kann die zahlen massiv gedrückt
und dann kam die videos mutation wo man
einfach auch wissenschaftlichen noch zu
wenig weiß wie sich wie sich diese
mutationen verhalten aber generell würde
ich sagen ja
für verschärfen ist da sinnvoller weg
und das heißt jetzt also dann jetzt
reagieren und die ansprechen also die
annalen ein
das noch fertig zu machen also die
anzeichen in deutschland deuten ja auch
darauf hin also es gibt noch weitere
verschärfungen aus
es ist nicht nur die mutation in irland
die hat natürlich ihren teil auch
vielleicht einen großen teil beigetragen
aber es war eben genau dass man hatte
den lockdown mann hatte die zahlen
gedrückt aber dann anfang dezember
gesagt so jetzt lasst uns mal
weihnachten feiern
lasst uns mal vor weihnachten feiern und
was bedeutet denn weihnachten feiern
zusammen kommen menschenansammlungen
super special events und genau das ist
passiert die virologen haben damals ich
habe selbst mit einem aus dublin gespann
gesagt wenn wir diesen weg gehen bevor
wir den nächsten höhepunkt und genau das
ist passiert und das sind dass wir immer
wieder die gleichen beispiel und das
deckt sich auch mit großbritannien ist
es immer wieder dieses wir wollen uns
irgendwie was auch bodo ramelow wenn ich
das richtig verstanden habe das nur aus
der ferne beobachtet ja ich habe so
gehofft dass es
wie anders kommt aber es gibt keine
hoffnung es ist ein virus ist ein
naturwissenschaftliches phänomen deshalb
seine gesetzmäßigkeiten ist mathematik
und wenn man darauf hört hört man glaube
ich besser und das ist die lehre aus
irland und auch aus großbritannien setzt
alles auf diese impfkampagne ich finde
ganz unabhängig davon ob man das dann im
nachgang als politischen erfolg für den
einen oder anderen irgendwie verbuchen
kann
würde also ist das ein punkt den termin
in deutschland tatsächlich auch noch
viel geld dass man das impfen viel
positiver verkauft viel mehr auf
kommunikation setzt einen schlag jetzt
über irgendwelche im pflichten zu
diskutieren die einfach ganz praktisch
ja auch nicht umsetzbar sind wir haben
einfach die logistik und den impfstoff
dafür noch nicht einfach klar zu machen
und das ist finde ich eine ziemlich
einfache botschaft das impfen ist der
weg schlechthin wir haben keinen andern
es gibt keine wirksame medikamente wir
müssen impfen oder das muss man positiv
in kampagnen verkaufen das muss man mit
positiven botschaften vermitteln und und
schneller impfen und ich glaube da kann
man schon also mit viel mehr nachdruck
und bis dahin diese effect 2 masken
pflicht diese dafür würde das dann
helfen würden sie sagen dass man auch
das könnte man ja jetzt
bundeseinheitlich sagen aber da müsste
man natürlich auch an alle machten
ausgeben weil die meisten sind teurer
als andere
viele werden sagen das ist mir zu teuer
und ja da wurde ja in bayern auch selber
schnell nachgesteuert also er hat sie da
hat ja an einem tag
diese p2 macht nicht angekündigt für den
öffentlichen nahverkehr und läden
dann kam die große kritik das ist nicht
sozial verträglich ist was ich auch
teile ein hartz4 empfänger oder sozial
schwächer gestellte menschen können sich
das nicht leisten weil diese masken treu
da sind also wenn man das tatsächlich
auch in anderen ländern einführen will
dann finde ich muss das auch verbunden
sein mit einem freien zugang mindestens
für bedürftige und dann wird die gäste
oder dann wird es bürokratisch natürlich
wieder ein aufwand nachzuweisen wer
bekommt sie jetzt
gratis und wer nicht die sprachen der
kampagne an wie ist denn das ist ja
kommunikation ist ja extrem wichtig in
diesen zeiten und an transparenz auch
und das gefühl man muss die bürger hier
weil es immer so schön heißt mitnehmen
wie ist es in frankreich frau welche
rolle hat da makro der ja selber auch
jetzt positiv war also wie wird er
akzeptiert und dann macht der da eine
gute figur was die kommunikation
betrifft nein also das problem ist
frankreich hat im märz ganz ganz spät
reagiert und da frankreich spät reagiert
hatte wir hatten die kapazitäten ich
werden die masken nicht wir hatten keine
finanziellen mittel für die
krankenhäuser zur verfügung gestellt und
das hat die regierung damals wäre so das
zu vertuschen unter dem motto alles gut
bleiben sie zu hause die masken helfen
sowieso nicht das haben wir ein bisschen
hier in deutschland gehört aber nicht in
der dimension den frankreich das wurde
lange lange lange gesagt wir haben
sowieso das beste gesundheitssystem der
welt und die masken brauchen wir nicht
und es wird alles gut und jetzt kommt
genau das gleiche problem
november wie die impfstrategie wenn wir
in deutschland ich hab auch artikel
geschrieben wo ich alle ok es wird hier
ins zentrum geben und das wird so durch
inländer organisiert und dies und das
rad frankreich erst anfang dezember sich
so es war so ein krisenkomitee makro
entscheidet immer alleine wo sie
anfangen sagt er wie fangen wir dann an
und dann als die erste woche von januar
diese große skandal da an geht also
passierte keine ihm klar so da hat der
müsse wachsen der gouverneur anfang
gesagt ich bin aber kein logistikexperte
mensch warum bist du denn da seit einem
monat beschäftigt das ist also die die
wissenschaftler die forscher die
mediziner haben diesem hilft entwickelt
deinen job ist dass der impfstoff zu den
franzosen kommt und das war und es habe
jetzt kommt jetzt die situation wo wir
wissen es gibt diese britische mutation
in frankreich nichtsdestotrotz sagt die
briten die französische regierung alles
gut wir lassen alle sowie das ist kein
gefahr für die schulen keine gefangenen
lehne und so weiter und da kommt dieses
misstrauen sehr kleine musik die wir
seit anfang an der in der in der
pandemie immer höheren da sagen die
franzosen
ok ich freue mich jetzt mehr freiheit
als die deutschen oder
die briten aber was versteckt dass inter
gibt es vielleicht doch nicht irgendwas
schief ist da und sofort kam dieses
misstrauen in displays trill firma gehen
und dann man auch da muss man auch gegen
den eben stoffen kritisch und all diese
sachen sagt in der letzten runde würde
ich ganz gerne mal von ihnen gehören der
link weiter gibt es was wenn jetzt aus
ihrer erfahrung in israel dann ist es
ein viel kleineres land man kann es
nicht 100 prozent natürlich vergleichen
mit deutschland aber wo sie sagen das
wäre ein punkt den könnte man jetzt
schnell auch aus israel eigentlich
übernehmen für deutschland damit wir
irgendwie besser diese impfung
organisieren und besser durch diesen
lockdown kommen also ein neues konzept
was was hier demnächst vielleicht
wirklich an den markt geht ist der grüne
impfpass alle die sich impfen lassen und
dann auch die zweite dosis erhalten
haben also eine woche später dann
wirklich endgültig als immun gelten soll
dieses zertifikat bekommen durch geimpft
zu sein und damit wieder zugang zu
bekommen zu kulturveranstaltungen ins
café gehen dürfen und auch wieder reisen
dürfen und von der quarantäne
ausgenommen zu werden
das gilt übrigens schon ab jetzt wer
also die zweite impfung bekommen hat
muss nicht mehr bei einer rückkehr nach
israel in die obligatorische zweiwöchige
quarantäne
das ist also ein anreiz ja das ist eine
wenn man so will subtile kampagne einen
anreiz für alle das zu tun wenn man so
will auch ein wink mit dem zaunpfahl
halber werden den pastor nicht hat der
hat es sozial dann etwas schwieriger
jährlich kommt ist noch nicht ganz
sicher aber es zeichnet sich ab ok wurde
hier sehr kritisch diskutiert eigentlich
eher dass man sagt man will keine
sonderrechte für geimpfte wie sie das
finde ich ja sehr interessanten punkt
wird sowas auch in großbritannien
diskutiert er stammt sonderrechte
vergeben es gab diese überlegungen aber
die haben nie wirklich weit geführt muss
man sagen es ist liegt vielleicht auch
mit der grundsätzlichen abneigung der
briten hat er dann etwas zu tun dass man
mit diesem meldesystem und so
verpflichtende sachen und es gibt ja
nicht mehr personal aus weil sie hier
da wird man sicher hat man sich lange
oder wehrt man sich
erfolgreich dagegen manche wollten das
einführen also ich glaube das ist nicht
der der britische weg wenn es da keiner
wenn es wenn es gefordert wird von
ländern wenn man in einen flug antreten
muss und dann wird man das natürlich
irgendwie organisieren können aber das
ist nicht der britisch ich glaube der
britische weg ist jetzt eben impfen
impfen impfen und und frau wolf hatte so
ein bisschen schon vorweggenommen ist
glaube ich dieser positiven spirit dem
man den ganzen gibt das wird das zieht
sich auch durch die medien das ist so
ein bisschen vielleicht auch patriotisch
aber in diesem fall ist es eben
hilfreich denn am ende ist es egal ob es
politiker nutzt es muss den menschen
nutzen und das tut es natürlich und da
wird eben auch mal verknüpft willst du
sommer in spanien in der sonne sitzen
dann lass dich impfen ich meine so
einfach kann es dann manchmal sein das
ist einleuchtend und wenn man zur
normalität zurück will dann eben nur
über das impfen und das ist vielleicht
das was deutschland sich von
großbritannien abschauen kann und dann
auch mal fünfe gerade sein lassen und ja
es ist eine ausnahmesituation lange
lässt man fünfe gerade sein eben in
ausnahmen sind so und ich hoffe er dass
man so eine situation nicht alle jahre
wieder erledigt werden der wand haben
frauke gibt's was wo sie sagen das
könnten wir in deutschland übernehmen
frank hat also die situation momentan
ist ein bisschen kompliziert also ich
finde schon diese rasante beschleunigung
der impfkampagne in der letzten zehn
tagen ist schon beeindruckend also es
funktioniert tatsächlich und leute
bekommen richtig e mails oder sms jetzt
sind sie jetzt ran und das gibt ziemlich
schnell das ja also ich muss sagen dass
wir schon mal anfangen mit der leute die
75 jahre alt sind
das könnte schon schnell gehen momentan
fühle ich mich aber sicher hier also ich
muss sagen auch als mutter ist es sehr
schwierig die kinder zu hause zu haben
aber ich glaube schon würde ich in
frankreich seien also wäre ich in
frankreich für dich schon mal ein
bisschen angst haben viele kinder
ok also wir was positives was nicht so
positiv ist frau wolf haben sie den
eindruck dass man in der deutschen
politik wirklich auch nach israel zurück
geschaut und davon was lernen möchte
naja was das impfen angeht glaube ich
schon aber es ist tatsächlich auch weil
auf vielen ebenen einfach nicht
vergleichbar sind viel kleiner das land
und ich meine die die infektionszahlen
sind
auch hoch es ist jetzt nicht so dass das
impfen die schnelligkeit beim üben das
problemlos und sie rechnen sie jetzt
auch noch mal mit einer verschärfung ab
der nächsten woche
ja wir sind gespannt das war ganz
sicherlich nicht die letzte phoenix
runde zum thema corona dann ganz
herzlichen dank nach london nach tel
aviv und in ihrem studio und noch einen
schönen tag und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]